grave on continue quand même bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
géographe spécialiste de la Russie vous
êtes le temps de nombreux ouvrages et
articles sur la Russie le Caucase les
états postes soviétiques vous êtes
auteur de cet ouvrage à part apparaître
pardon dans dans 2 jours ce sera le 23
février réussi un vertige de puissance
aux éditions La Découverte merci d'être
avec nous à mot peut-être déjà pour
commenter cette intervention de la
lumière Poutine on entendait notre
correspondant à Moscou à l'entendre on a
presque le sentiment finalement que le
chef du Kremlin aujourd'hui inverse
complètement les rôles c'est l'Occident
qui a attaqué à l'entendre l'Ukraine
victime aujourd'hui les Russes font tout
leur possible pour défendre les intérêts
ukrainiens
oui ça c'est ton discours traditionnel
déjà ça fait plusieurs années que
Vladimir Poutine accuse l'Occident
d'agression et en particulier en février
2022 l'an dernier donc voici un an le
discours rue c'est nous nous répliquons
à une agression potentielle de l'OTAN et
de l'Occident par les graines alors
évidemment c'est une inversion totale là
la lumière Poutine a un peu précisé son
propos en disant que cet agression selon
lui aurait commencé dès 2014
c'est-à-dire dès 2014 l'armée
ukrainienne et aidé par les forces
occidentales à commencer à empiéter sur
des régions que Vladimir Poutine dans
son dans son discours historique
complètement réinventé attribue à la
Russie donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
avait déjà entendu
je dirais que
premièrement ce discours de 1h50 était
destiné à montrer à la population russe
que le président va bien il est en forme
il parle plus d'une heure 50 sans boire
un verre d'eau certains annonçaient
d'ailleurs qu'il allait peut-être
prononcé un discours un peu plus un peu
plus concis une quarantaine de minutes
c'est ce qu'on disait en coulisse oui
mais les rumeurs vont bon train et la
réalité de Vladimir Poutine et celle-là
celle d'un président en forme un chef de
guerre incontestablement c'est un
discours de mobilisation alors peut-être
que nous nous allons retenir les deux
annonces qu'il a fait la suspension du
new start d'une part et la possibilité
de faire de nouveaux essais nucléaires
si les Américains commencent à en faire
mais en réalité l'essentiel du discours
c'est un programme de développement
d'une économie de guerre une
mobilisation sans précédent de la
population russe des des entrepreneurs
russes avec toute une série de mesures
très détaillées dans tous les domaines
le domaine une économique le domaine des
infrastructures le domaine de
l'éducation de domaine des universités
le domaine de la santé versez c'est un
programme essentiellement destiné à
mobiliser la population en russe d'une
façon positive en disant effectivement
nous avons résisté au sanctions nous
résisterons aux sanctions et toutes les
la volonté de nous de nous vaincre ne
fonctionnera pas c'est ça l'essentiel un
discours aussi peut-être dessiné à faire
taire les critiques on commence à
entendre ici et là à convaincre
évidemment cette population un an après
le début de l'offensive l'anniversaire
ce sera donc vendredi lui qui promettait
une opération spéciale éclaire
fulgurante de trois jours on est un an
après on en est toujours au même point
on parle même dans les mois aujourd'hui
des forces russes
c'est évident que le projet initial de
renverser le gouvernement ukrainien de
Monsieur zellenski et de nous prendre la
capitale Kiev à échouer il est clair que
l'armée russe a échoué dans ses
objectifs initiaux
et elle a échoué ensuite grâce à la
capacité et de l'armée ukrainienne
complètement reboostée par des alliés
occidentaux et armés par ces lieux
occidentaux donc effectivement l'armée
russe est en échec mais maintenant on
est dans une autre phase et on est dans
une autre guerre je dirais que on est on
rentre dans une nouvelle phase de ce
conflit avec à la fois
un pourrissement sur place on ne sait
pas de quoi demain sera fait il n'a pas
donné du tout de détails sur ces
intentions et au fond il a peu détaillé
la question militaire proprement dit
est-ce que vous êtes déçu à ce niveau là
c'est vrai qu'il y a certains
commentateurs qui disent on s'attendait
peut-être à une à une prise de parole un
peu plus forte un discours un peu plus
vaste en guerre avec l'annonce d'une
nouvelle mobilisation l'annonce aussi de
cette grande offensive qu'on prédit pour
le printemps prochain donc je crois
qu'il faut se méfier des rumeurs on
Poutine nous a habitué aux surprises et
il s'en est félicité à plusieurs
reprises vous voyez moi je suis capable
de prendre de décision que personne
n'attend
en l'occurrence c'était pas le cas pour
le 24 février parce que les États-Unis
avaient annoncé à l'avance que
la lumière Poutine allait attaquer mais
il n'a pas du tout détaillé c'est clair
c'était pas son intention c'est pas
maintenant qu'il va faire ça ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'y aura pas d'offensive
russe on n'en sait rien c'est compliqué
parce que l'offensive russe ça
impliquerait de masser des troupes or la
technologie américaine qui aide
l'Ukraine de surveillance au sol minute
par minute est-elle que la moindre
la moindre préparation d'une attaque
russe sera
prévue à la vente de la même façon donc
c'est cette expérience un jeu très
compliqué
et donc on est dans cette phase nouvelle
qui aussi de plus en plus peut
ressembler à une une guerre frontale
entre les deux super puissants ou en
tout cas la superpuissance américaine et
l'ancienne superpuissance affaiblir
russe et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
d'une autre nature et qui est une sorte
de il faut se méfier de cette de cette
trajectoire qui qui au fond change
l'échelle de la guerre change l'échelle
des perceptions de cette guerre et on
verra qu'est-ce qui va comment ça va se
dérouler il faut avoir
pardon il faut avoir la teneur du
discours aussi de Joe Biden ce soir
depuis depuis Varsovie ce sera l'autre
grande séquence du jour le chef de
l'OTAN vient de saltenberg vient à
l'instant de commencer de commenter les
déclarations de la lumière Poutine il se
dit de plus en plus inquiet d'un
possible soutien militaire de de Pékin
amosku ça ce sont les Américains qui
accusent la Chine de vouloir armer
soutenir militairement les forces les
forces russes est-ce que c'est une
option possible pour vous Pékin a
démenti hier et est-ce que c'est de
nature a inquiéter aussi
c'est sûr que c'est inquiétant
Pékin a démenti ce qui ne veut pas dire
que les Chinois n'aident pas les Russes
d'autres façons parce que ils les aide
en fournissant un certain nombre de
matériel pas forcément des armes mais la
technologie qui peut éventuellement
avoir des des utilisations duales
c'est-à-dire être à la fois
civil et militaire et d'autre part il
les aident en achetant du gaz du pétrole
etc alors est-ce qu'ils vont les aider
militairement les Chinois n'ont pas
vraiment démenti ils ont dit que c'était
absurde que c'était pas que ça
et ils ont ils ont démenti en accusant
les instrumentaux de fournir beaucoup
d'armes à l'Ukraine ce qui est une façon
de dire à un moment donné si les Chinois
jugent que cette aide militaire
occidentale à l'Ukraine et est
disproportionné ou en tout cas fournit
des armes d'une autre nature c'est à
dire que les
Ukrainiens demandent par exemple des
avions de chasse les Chinois pourraient
alors considérer ils sont libérés de
leurs paroles de ne pas fournir d'âmes
et qu'ils vont en fournir après on verra
quels sont les ces armes et en quelle
quantité merci beaucoup Jean rad vanille
merci d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
le titre de votre ouvrage apparaître
dans deux jours aussi un vertige de
puissance vous réagissiez donc à cette
intervention de Vladimir Poutine un
discours sur l'état de la nation